yourself
hey i'm nick
and i'm kira
and this is
drop live live
woo
yay
okay so today we're going to be drawing
you guys profile pictures so go on
twitter and use the hashtag drawofflive
post your stuff we're going to scroll
through the tag and we're going to
choose at random who we want to draw
so get to it yeah hang on i'm updating
the links
streamlink
you know what let's let's have you do
that one more time
just to make sure we're live
sure
reintroduce ourselves yeah
go ahead
all right
hey i'm nick hey i'm kira
and this is draw off live
main camera okay um
so today we're going to be drawing you
guys profile pictures so if you go on
twitter and you use the hashtag
drawofflive post your selfies characters
whatever you want to do we will choose
things that we want to draw and draw it
for you live
so get
hashtagging
and we'll look at our phones yeah let me
pull up
taggers
i don't know we'll take a look at our
phones
the chat is going back too fast
okay let me look
uh
oh oh i see some cats kyra oh i see some
cats yes send me pictures of your pet
kaelin kaitlyn
kira loves drawing pets i love
i love drawing weird stuff just saying
let's see i'm waiting for it to load oh
oh my god this one person has seven cats
let's see
kailyn
i want to draw your cat
but you have to draw you have to draw
all seven right
she only posted two
okay you make up the other seven this is
going to be very improv because it's
it's live
what are you gonna draw
um
i'm still
looking
see
kitty
hmm
you said you saw a guy holding a bunny i
did
i did i'm trying to find that one again
my phone suddenly
oh no
i'm drawing kaylin's cat their username
on twitter is kalyn b underscore 21 and
i'm gonna draw their gray fluffy cat
we're kind of uh afraid to draw
selfies just because
we want to do you guys justice and i
feel bad if i like
can't make you as beautiful as you are
oh my god
look at pickles
pickles
oh my god i think i'm gonna have to draw
pickles
oh my god
yes
i think i found it we're going to draw
pickles
amazing
the username is
uh
uh oh
it's at crystal stromer
so right like right that top of the uh
oh yeah let's write you guys hashtags
all right
okay
all right crystal
don't worry you're getting pickles
this will be the first one
i'm sure we'll be doing multiple so
right yes okay
okay
both starting with cats
good choice i mean what better way to
start off in a live internet feed than
drawing cats right
and and this is like it's a hairless cat
pickles is such a good name for a cat
yes
okay
all right
now i'm suddenly realizing i don't know
how to draw cats oh boy i don't know how
to draw anything and you came on this
show okay
drawing a cat
with no hair
named pickles maybe if i draw pickles as
a pickle like a pickle cat
draw them in a pickle costume in a
pickle costume
but it's
pickles has a little it's a little like
jack-o'-lantern like a little you should
make it a pickle hat a pickle hat yeah
okay maybe let me get a pickle hat
kitty
all right
i'm gonna try to draw these like pretty
fast so i can get as many in as possible
so they're not gonna be like the most
pristine beautiful drawings in the world
but
none of my drawings on this show
are ever
pristine
let's see pickles
the adorable cat kitty
i want to see the guy holding the rabbit
i just want to draw bunnies
give you guys some user names can you
shout them out
sure all right say hi to
bob candy sugar man
bob can you sugar man that is a
fantastic
that name oh my god
mr tophat mr another excellent one
mr tophat what's up mr tophat thanks for
watching
hopefully you're enjoying our drawings
because i'm not enjoying my drawing so
far no
yeah it's okay it's okay
oh this kitty
everyone has such good user names i know
i need a better
it's just my name
i don't even know what my username is
it's so hard to like pick
i like when you go on websites and you
see people have usernames that are just
like i couldn't think of a username
this kitty is gray
okay wait let's
now
fantastic name for a cat sounds like mr
nuggets a fan of the nugs
stop messaging me oh my mom's watching
really just insulting hi kira's mom hi
how are you
[Music]
just look at my phone stomach sushi
okay
sure
kitties
oh we don't have a time limit this time
just spend the entire time drawing mr
pickles i think mine's going to be about
10 minutes of drawing mr pickles and
then it's going to be about 20 minutes
of profusely apologizing that i drew mr
pickles and
drew it in the way i'm drawing it i want
to see him
all right i'm going to give him a pickle
head wait i gotta size this up though
man
send me your animals
no
usually that works
mr i can't really
i don't know this kitty's name
i think the eyes are like silver
just
cool i've never had a cat
have you
okay we're definitely
he's focused
he's trying to do mr pickles justice
shout out to
crafty libra
crafty crafty
shout
that could be out you know since i just
had my birthday and i'm like cancer i
should call my i should be uh emotional
cancer
it was nick's birthday yeah yesterday
yeah we sang him happy birthday very
creepily creepily yeah it was the
creepiest happy birthday song i've ever
heard you're saying it really slow
mr pickles
the pickle-headed cat
people tell me happy birthday oh thank
you everybody how old are you i am 16.
i'm kidding i am now 37.
you act like you're so old you're so
young i know
uh
nick shout out to skyler
oh skylar at rec room what what what's
up skyler
i'm just gonna look at like fake cameras
everywhere what's up skyler
i know you're screaming like crazy right
now because i just said your name
is that internet friend
okay
all right i think i've done
uh oh this kitty kyra
wait
grab the username and then i can do more
let's see
just save everything to the desktop like
say make the file name
twitter like restarted itself
clay nationally
sounds like claymation
yeah
oh there's a there's a pug
we're all just gonna end up drawing
animals it's all gonna be animals i'm
kidding i i i am serious i like weird
stuff so post some weird stuff post you
are more likely to be picked if you
choose very bizarre things
that's their whole user
um
pickle does oh it doesn't look like
pickles has a tail
oh
okay
yeah uh i'm not quite getting the
anatomy of mr pickles right but please
forgive me crystal
i'm doing the best i can
under the pressure of drawing live in
front of
people
i don't know how many people but people
oh yeah so we gotta we got a question
here
from melody thurman she says hi i'm an
artist too i was wondering if you have
any tips on to improve art in general
i've been practicing a lot and it's
helped wonders but are there any tips
you could get her name is melody
melody thurman hey
um honestly i think the best thing to do
is practice uh it it's like that one uh
what is it like 10 000
uh hour theory where it's like you just
got to keep drawing and drawing and just
going away at what you were doing and
you'll improve
like it takes a while um
usually what helped me get better with
drawing was i would find movies or
you know just other artists that i liked
and studied their art and i saw how they
did it
and you can practice like i don't think
there's anything wrong with um
like tracing or referencing for practice
so long as you like make sure not to
claim that it's yours
but uh but yeah most artists i know
usually
get to where they are by just
drawing a lot of
characters they like or yeah
i mean it is it's it's like i tell
people all the time it's just draw draw
draw draw draw i mean honestly like i
should be drawing more than i draw
um because it's just the more you draw
the better you get and definitely like
copying
you know it sounds
like you shouldn't do that but really
like that's the best way to learn
because you're copying from other people
that already solved problems that maybe
you have yeah and and you're learning it
and
um i mean i used to do that a lot when i
was younger i would copy like disney
cartoons and nickelodeon and
um
things that i liked
and it helped me to become
the wonderful artist that i am today
hey
sorry pickles
and also like
nick is an amazing artist and animator
and he's been doing it for a while and
he still refuses to accept the fact that
he's good
and so do i like i feel like that's
that's another thing as an artist you
are forever improving and critiquing
yourself yeah the bar keeps being raised
but no just like
we're all in this together we're all
drawing yeah and the thing you always
remember too is like
people
everybody is at their own stage in their
journey as an artist you know like some
people are like really
far advanced and have been studying it
all their lives other people maybe not
so much so don't judge yourself
against other people only judge yourself
against your work if what you're drawing
is better than what you did like the
week before or a month before a year
that's good
yeah um
it's it's when you start judging other
people that you
you know your stuff against other people
that then you start feeling down and
yeah art is not a competition there's no
first place there's always going to be
an artist that's like better than you
and then an artist better than them and
an artist better than them and someone
like
i
most people when they look at art they
don't
like sit there and be like well you're
the best artist
ever
you know like this artist is the best
artist in the world
and nobody can beat them i mean some
people are like that but i don't know
the more art the merrier not a
competition try not to compare yourself
to others because
it's it's not worth it you'll drive
yourself totally insane if you do
and and
have fun with it because it's art you
get to create and it's
and especially now like when you get to
the point where you're getting paid to
do it
it's it's like the greatest like you're
you're actually creating
on a daily basis and getting paid
it's awesome yes
put my phone down
ah i'm almost done with this one
oh surprise guest
yes
oh my god
they're trying to fit through the door
everyone we have a surprise visitor
come
hello
come all the way around behind me all
screwed in you're good
oh my gosh hey copy copy how are you
[Laughter]
so
we have a surprise
to go along with guppy so
this no not this saturday next saturday
at comic-con on saturday the 20th
i am going to be there
signing a good advice cupcake
stuff i'm gonna be autographing things
so if you are at comic-con on saturday
the 20th come up to the sales pavilion
on the second level
i'm reading from a card
aa22
um and from 3 to 5 pm i'm gonna be
signing stuff because i i have a secret
to expose that a lot of people don't
know
um i'm the good advice cupcake no way
so i voiced the character and i'm the
lead animator on the project so um yeah
if you're at comic con totally stop by
on uh
sales pavilion second level aa22 three
to five pm saturday july 20th
you'll be there too cuppy will be there
so you can get a picture with guppy
we love you cuppy we love you cubby
thank you for coming in i'm glad you fit
through the door
bye
bye
bye
i'll see you on saturday oh my god
that's okay siri
all right
um
this is
this is not
the slowest drawing process
but yes
good advice cupcake so you're the voice
of good advice cupcake yeah oh m g
on the voice of
cuppy and i'm also the voice of cookie
wow
and the voice of bun
and the cat
but ye
speaking of cats i think i am pretty
much almost done with this cat and i
will be moving on i am really excited to
see
i'm not excited for you to see it
i'm drawing like the most adorable dog
all right
crystal
i apologize
to mr pickles no
you probably did a great job
uh let's see we will call this
this dog is so cute
let's see
this dog is owned by
the dog's name riley
it's so cute
and the username is ryrie
jenks i think
right
[Music]
let's see
this is just gonna be like a pet drawing
show
i'll draw people
come on twitter
yeah guys go on twitter and use the
hashtag drawofflive and if you post
anything there
we might draw it
please post some
hilarious things
so that nick and i can provide you with
interesting content
people want you to draw people
they want us to draw people
oh let's see
of course they want us to draw people
they want us to draw them
the thing that we're most afraid to draw
i can't i can draw people i'm just i
don't like offending people
i'll draw i'll make you very cute
i hate do you ever get people where
they're like can you draw me but draw me
like real like
realistically like how i look
um
like be honest yeah and then i usually
tell them i'm like i'm an animator i
will draw you as a cartoon
i don't know
oh my god
like i've had some people where they're
like please draw me but like definitely
don't be afraid to accentuate my
like features and i'm like
offend you
if i draw you bad i got
i got one i'm gonna draw
this one is squid girl
i think yep squid
girl uh we got look at that look at that
expression
fantastic oh my god yeah make weird
faces see that
there's a fantastic expression
perfect for drawing a
cartoon look at this dog that i drew
nick
oh it's so cute oh my god
that's a cute dog
i am all right
here we go squid girl
oh
okay
this is
change my opacity
wait list
oh
squid
okay i'll draw a person let's see jay
there's so many cute dogs
all right here we go
okay i think you're going to draw love
me 91393
sounds like a like i just repeated like
a
zip code
it's like the the
spin off seriously 90210 902
i'm probably going to draw like busts i
feel like it's it's probably easier
yeah heads
someone comes on they're like please
only draw my body
all right
like to make the expression when i'm
drawing the expression
because it helps me to get the
expression
oh yeah um if any of you guys are
artists uh
you might also do that thing where when
you're drawing an expression like nick
says
you are simultaneously making the
expression
the amount of times where people have
like come over and they're like are you
okay and i'm sitting there like making a
weird face
that's too many times
okay
we're going to start over squid girl
we're going to start over i don't know
about that one
try this again
okay
oh drawing people
hey luna desserts hi luna dessert
that's so funny when we were doing shout
outs before and i just yelled shout out
it wasn't a shout out at all
year
hey mackenzie what's up mackenzie
thanks for watching
we can't see what's going on in the
comments shout out panda cookie
panda cookie hey panda cookie
oh my god noticing everybody has such
sweet usernames delicious
cookie man
let's see
says love you guys oh thank you leela
thank you i love you too
thank you thank you
you know we all love all of you too in
watching
us draw
watching the struggle
the struggle is real
i i still like have
ipad
on the brain
because i'll go to like do an ipad
feature instead of
desktops so you do you draw a lot on
your ipad now yeah mostly
that's pretty cool you had an astro pad
you said yeah i use astro pad on my ipad
it's pretty good it allows me to use my
ipad as a cintiq
it's so cool
um wacom is fantastic too i love the
wacom cintiq
i just
i needed to
downsize because i had a kid and had to
get rid of my wacom
god i miss my wacom
but you use one every day but i use it
every day at work so
yeah oh my god welcome to like
jalen simmer says you guys inspired me
to get better ever since the amazing art
of post being started uh series started
thank you guys that's james simmer jalen
simmer thank you so much for the sweet
comment i'm so happy that like this
show's been able to help like
anybody it's awesome
oh you're welcome
it's a great name
he is so smoky he's so cute
he makes his hat bigger
i can't wait to see pickles
oh
my god
so when you guys are done drawing the
ones you're currently drawing we're
gonna
video
let's see glasses
lauren brown 147 says uh did you guys go
to college for arts
we did yeah so we went to college for
our um
you go first where did you go i went to
calarts which is up in
uh kind of north of la and studied
character animation there
um
and it was a lot of fun
what about you kyra so i
i was on the opposite coast and i went
to sva
which is a fantastic school i love
everyone there
um
yeah sva was great and it's um it's
really crazy because like
when i first attended sva
uh
people were kind of like
like lesser cal arts and like making fun
of us
but now sva is like super popular like
to the point where uh some people can't
even get in
because
they've just had like a huge flood of
submissions which is fantastic but
sad for people who can't get in yeah and
i mean you know that's definitely
happens to a lot of people like they'll
apply and they don't get in right away
but it doesn't mean that you can't
reapply and keep going and trying you
know
yeah and
another thing
on the topic of art college is like
if you can't go to art college it is not
the end of the world especially for
animation
um i know so many people who couldn't
afford to go
or
didn't want to go and they did
fantastically like yeah
it's
yeah it's not the end of the world if
you're unable to attend there's also
there's so many resources nowadays to
learn art
that you don't yeah you could just learn
online you know force came to worse you
could just watch youtube videos and
read books
yeah
i mean if there were the resources when
i was in school that there are today i
would have been like wow
i know
all these tablets saved me in school
it's like all i used
see my day we drew on paper it
we did draw on paper at school though we
did have light disks for a short time i
don't know if they're still there
people were telling me that they
i think got rid of them
but it's cool to
do animation traditionally
all right squid girl
i also apologize to you
stop apologizing you're doing great
i walk over and it's like really
oh
offensive
like
no
okay
once you guys are done with these go
ahead and start a new
uh
1200
sure
okay how am i going to make these
glasses
shaky line art
nick what's your favorite program to
draw in
my favorite program is probably now uh
procreate which is on the ipad i love it
just become an ipad
i i love it i mean i love i love
photoshop and i love working on it but
uh i'm always on the go and going around
and like you know drawing in cafes and
stuff and
it's it's nice to be able to have
basically something that is almost as
good as photoshop
that you can use on the fly so you can
still use color and
and paint you know i used to
bring a backpack with me that had like
all my paints and colors in it and so i
would like
go drawing and painting
and it's just easier to pull out a
tablet and just go now the cool thing is
photoshop's coming for the ipad soon i
can't wait
yeah what about
you so i
i love so many programs uh i use i've
always used photoshop a lot um and of
course our favorite flash
frames
flashes
you're a big flash stan
big for animation
and uh what else
tv paint
really good
um
tv paint
is like the program that we learned at
school primarily and then
i wanted to use it when i started
working here but then flash just ended
up being
like a more intelligent choice because
of the vector based
you know you can resize things and it
won't get pixely
very close
so nick on your machine we're gonna do
the screen recordings also okay
it's kind of hard to draw just one hand
okay
while we wait
i'm just gonna draw
a sad man
who has one arm
too big i don't know what i'm doing
guys this is like the most skewed
oh my god yeah
i gotta fix it
so i should have drawn someone like
super cartooning because that's what i
like
so exaggerated you can't even recognize
them
i'm gonna do the
one eyebrow up one eyebrow down
dreamworks
yeah
okay i think look all right
sure
save it as a photoshop file
so uh to everybody whose drawings that
we drew we're going to tweet them once
we're finished and
[Laughter]
get ready for it
so and now what we're going to do is
we're going to actually do a
real episode of draw off and record it
so you guys can all see how it works and
what it's like to record it
recording
please leave
is yours
is it
uh let's just do 1200 by 1200.
i like how you knew that
what my question was going to be
draw off live scene one alpha take one
all three cameras are rolling hey mark
b mark
and c mic
all right
are they all rolling
so you guys can do your sides
yay we get our cameras what's up what's
up
what's up my peeps hello
all right so let's start we'll start
with you nick so hi i'm nick hi i'm kyra
and today we are drawing uh
selfies in our own style based off of a
hashtag all right
hi i'm nick hey i'm kira and today we're
drawing
selfies in our style based on the
hashtag hashtag
this one yeah it's looking at the center
one so today we're going to be drawing
selfies in our style from the hashtag
hashtag
all right
okay okay so more of the same
let's see
so
we've got some awesome
drawings that are here or not drawings
i'm sorry we've got some awesome
pictures to look at
and um
going to draw
someone sent a picture of their goat
a goat
oh i see it
so good queen of sheba
that's the greatest
goat name ever
oh puppy
there's a cat wearing a naruto headband
i need to draw
one more kitty
okay
naruto kitty
from
natasha uh
how spicy that's what i'm drawing
in the middle
yeah
come here
okay let's see i wish phones didn't
black out so quick
oh man
this is seeing us at our most
artistically vulnerable because we uh
don't even really have time to think so
natu
has
a drawing or a drawing i keep saying
it's a drawing it's a picture of an
adorable dog in a cowboy outfit i saw oh
i think i'm gonna have to draw that baby
right now
so i am the rest of the cat's body is
cropped off from the photo so i'm just
gonna guess
all right
all right not too
again guys if you want us to draw your
stuff try posting it on twitter in the
hashtag drawofflive
and we will make an attempt
it looks kind of
kitty kind of sad
kind of like
why did you dress me in this
do you have any pets
i don't
get you some
i have a child
which is
well not really a pet but
we need a pet to clean up all the food
that my son drops oh that's what i miss
about having dogs like in my apartment
you drop something they'll just eat it
you don't even need a vacuum cleaner
you don't have any pets right now
well
my family does
uh
shout out to sky and dex
good doggies i'll see them
next week
um
they're my family's dog but
uh they live
downstate
so um
i only get to see them every so often
and we're not allowed to have pets at
our apartment
but oh
it's kind of like
you know like
work all the time i'd feel horrible
leaving an animal home alone yeah i just
no i definitely i want to be able to
be there for it
talk about uh your approach to drawing
this cat
okay so my approach for drawing this
naruto cat is he looks he or she looks
very
kind of pissed off in the picture
it's funny because the the naruto
headband is not even real it's like a
sticker it's not even wearing it and
it's pissed off
it just senses it
so i'm gonna try to make it
real cutesy big body
big body
big head tiny body
let's give it a down tail
um
i love when pets are drawed
drawed
can't speak at all
i love when pets are drawn
in a very uh
cheeby cutesy big eyed style
i like when pets are drawn
in any way because it's adorable
how are you approaching drawing animals
uh
i'm just kind of looking at it and and
just kind of finding features that jump
out to me you know like i was drawing
these big he
he or she
i don't know
uh the dog had a really kind of like
these big eyebrows so i made these big
kind of sad eyebrows and
um
and then i'm just drawing the hat right
now and kind of
you know just just looking at things
where you know again it's like when
you're drawing you're drawing from life
so you find the things that are in life
and then caricature it and exaggerate it
and
um
and that's kind of what i'm doing
have you ever had one of those
experiences where you like kind of have
always drawn something or like
recognized a concept mostly from
animation and then when you see it in
real life it like trips you out because
you're like
it really do be like
oh i know yeah
you're just like wait a minute at least
sometimes i'll just look at my dog's
face and i'll just be like
the way that i draw is correct
sort of he does have a mask it do look
like that
and when i was talking about the mask i
talked about the eye and disney this is
called the eye mask which the like
squirrel mask
yeah it's like a raccoon mask raccoon
mask you could probably find info on the
internet about it this doesn't even look
like it's on his head but it's okay
because it's not even on his head for
real it's like a sticker
sheriff
kitties
this cat actually kind of
has similar markings to that little
puppy
let's see
my dog does have a widow's peak
this
[Music]
this outfit is so cute
look at this outfit he's so cute he or
she is so cute
okay kitty
oh
wait
these markings
he's gonna be
the most root and tootiness
dog cowboy in the old west
oh
look who's back
back again
i'm just going to assume the tail is
orange tail might not are brown
it might not even be
cuppy
there's that y'all are back
what's this oh my gosh please be careful
i'll scoot in
oh sweet okay
i've gotten some very important
instructions from cuffy
so
not this saturday next saturday
comic-con
is happening san diego comic-con
and i'm going to be there because i keep
doing that
i'm going to be there
um doing autographs on the sales
pavilion the second floor and it's um
yeah second level aa22
and i'm going to be doing it from 3 to 5
pm we'll be there with cuppy
so i'm going to be signing stuff so if
you're at san diego comic con on july
20th
which is a saturday
from three to five pm you can come say
hello to us
copy
yeah and um i think yeah i'll sign
anything just just bring me anything
bring me your animal i'll sign it
and um if you want to follow the good
advice cupcake make sure on instagram to
follow at the good advice cupcake on
instagram
i think that's all i had to say but yeah
saturday
cuppy thank you so much for dropping by
again
for for uh
stumbling into the room
whoo we love you cubs gave you a creepy
creepy wave
so yeah if you want a picture with cuppy
definitely show up on uh saturday at san
diego comic con on the 20th
oh my gosh
getting accustomed bye copy
bye
that's how you know it's live me
stumbling over uh
all this information but yeah
i will be there
and i will stumble in this a similar way
i'm really excited i've never been to uh
like inside san diego comic con
oh man comic-con is
fun
have you been to san diego
i have i am from san diego so there is a
time where
i used to go to comic-con all the time
that's awesome i love it and
unfortunately i won't be able to make it
this year because i'm going to be on
vacation or else i would totally be
there that's exciting
guppy you just met cuppy now i did
okay okay
back to drawing yeah let's get back to
drawing
yes
i always for some reason no there's a
perfectly good reason i zoom out a lot
on my drawings because sometimes i don't
want to look at those janky lines i want
to pretend that it's good
and zoom out that's how i watch
animation
my own animation
your cowboy doggie oh he's adorable so
cute he looks like a little
doggy teddy bear
a teddy dog
keep forgetting whiskers gotta add the
whiskers
merge
let's see and i'll draw a person after
this
this went by very fast
let's see
well thanks everybody for watching
and and supporting us thank you so much
sincerely
yeah let's shout out let's shout more
names out
this person is such a good user name
shout out derpy rainbow
hey derpy rainbow
oh my god of course
oh natasha yes so thank you so much
i love your kitty
what are their eye what's their eye
color let's see
emma line allen says hi
emmeline allen hey
hi emmeline allen
keep the eyes white
no we'll color them okay
okay
one more
who's it gonna be in 10 minutes did you
see the turtle sitting on the watermelon
yes i did i saw the turtle sitting on
the watermelon i almost did it because i
love watermelon and then i saw this
adorable dog
in a cowboy outfit
oh my gosh there's a german shepherd
puppy
oh
okay i'm gonna draw
wait
oh let's see
spending always
someone sent an image that's like
cracking me up
but like i don't know if i should draw
it
let's see
person person person
[Music]
my last one will be
tick tock tick tock miss j g
i will draw her
speed round
so can you write her first yes
all right
cowboy oh wait
the most important
couch
babe
the badge
we should give him a badge too actually
we should give him a big old
star
i'm wasting time
see gold
i just draw their name not them
shout out
now
is hello brush so big
see do i have time for one more
all right let's see uh super cartoony
okay
so i am trying to cartoonify you
draw you fast i'm sorry i'm not doing
you the most
justice all right
i'm gonna do it
sophia
we're gonna draw
the turtle
on the watermelon
yes such a good choice
and we're gonna do it really fast
this is this is going to be a gesture
drawing the lightning round i just
yep
wait i lost the turtle where's the
turtle
there it is
all right
so this is actually a good exercise to
do if you're
uh
one if you want to get an animation this
is like perfect it's you know looking at
a picture and drawing it quickly and
trying to get the essence of the drawing
freaking out really quick because how
how much longer do we have
we have five minutes we have five
minutes here we go turtle
on a watermelon
it's basically just two half moons
done
just kidding
all right
but that is kind of breaking down the
main shapes of like what you know i'm
looking at so
it's this cute little turtle with these
little squinty eyes
and just got this little mouth so it
just goes right
[Music]
so cute
i am a turtle
okay
this one's pretty good because uh
his arms and legs are inside a shell
right now so
less things
i use this
[Music]
yellow
lightning round
just blotch that color on
say hi to my family and my mom if you're
watching yeah hello nick's family hi
i made something of myself
i'm working huh
i'm live on the internet
so nick maybe tell us a little bit more
about like yesterday
so i mean it's it's it's really trying
to think about
the essence now i mean this is the
essence of this is a turtle
sitting on a watermelon but you you kind
of are drawing quick loose
uh the terms gestural hence gesture
drawings
and it's about
you know capturing a mood or
or a pose you know if you're doing life
drawing where you're drawing from a
figure then
you're trying to capture the essence of
the pose that the person is standing in
um this i'm just trying to capture just
the essence of
what's happening that there's a turtle
sitting on a watermelon and
um
it's it's really good to do because what
it does is it teaches you
how to draw quickly but also more
importantly it teaches you how to think
teaches you how to think about what
you're drawing and the choices that
you're making to create the drawing
as quickly as you can like what are the
least number of lines that you can use
to basically say this is
a turtle sitting on a watermelon
um
and
that's you know really the essence of
gesture drawing
um for for us as animators it's really
important because when we're
animating and drawing out our characters
we're drawing really quickly
and having to uh you know draw out our
poses and
and exaggerate and
gesture really allows you to do that
so
if you are wanting to get in a drawing
and animation just your drawing is
definitely something you want to do
so any final thoughts on
this experiment
very challenging it's very it's
challenging enough to draw characters
for memory
even more challenging to draw on a time
limit and even more challenging to draw
a live in front of an audience
but we hope you all enjoyed it and uh
you know
we'll be doing more i hope you're ready
for some prime entertainment from jackie
and brent and kevin
and everyone else
[Music]
okay and
hey to all
the rec room crew
let's
let's see what else was posted turtle
watermelon
oh the puppy is so cute
i think it's time that we i think it's
time for us to switch
it's sweat
this is the longest draw off ever
oh my gosh
we got to keep some but yeah everyone uh
we have more people coming on to draw so
keep sending those tweets in at hashtag
drawofflive
and people will be looking at that to
draw
yeah if you want your characters your
pets yourself
drawn
by the draw-off team just
you know do hashtag draw a fly like mr
pickles
i want to see him
mr pickles
i saw him want to see your drawing i
know are we going to get a look at our
drawings um
i want to see how awesome
your drawings are
let me see did i spell that name
correctly
did you see
uh
did you see this one
no
oh
this one's pretty awesome
i saw that i almost drew that one the
rat
who did it who posted it oh
shout out to
bleh
ashley style x style
there's a pink rat and it's super
awesome
um
dorsi cheyenne
uh this is a great drawing that you
posted
let's go ahead and cut these guys okay
all right
bye everybody
thank you guys so much
oh my gosh i can see your screen
wait
stop recording
it didn't record
okay wait they couldn't see your screen
because i can see yours
it's i don't know it should have
recorded
did it yeah it shaves it to the desktop
yeah i see it yeah weirdly enough it
went to the menu
okay okay okay
we shouldn't
okay
all right so stay right here and have
the guys come in
um i just want to turn off this engine
i need to check batteries
i got two bars we're still here yeah how
many bars do you have on your microphone
let's see
changing of the guard two
hello hey hello hello
they said stay
come on in swap out take your side
side
all right
oh should we take it off
hello
good luck well thank you
maybe we should draw the same
[Laughter]
can hear you jason
i can't see you yet go ahead okay
can i leave this here yeah
bye guys bye bye everybody
ah
okay
how are we doing
for each one and let's start a new 1200
by 1200
okay because we're drawing
all right
is it uh recording right now screen
recording i'm not gonna record we're
only gonna record the second half oh
okay
oh but this is like streaming now
okay
okay
so now i just gotta search some peeps
okay
okay
i'm gonna draw
the
this girl
oh there's a teletubby man that's kind
of fun
uh
someone just uploaded a picture of
sasuke
that's cool i'm gonna draw
uh danny
i see
so right write it real big
um okay
i'm not sure how to pronounce this name
but i kind of like the picture so i'm
just going to do it oh there's so many
more brush options i don't like it
like
why are all these options here
okay
america
oh
y'all know i'm jason
hello we're only the main camera riff
hey everyone
i'm brent
what's up
okay and i'm drawing this person
her handle she
looks pretty cool
all right
okay
okay
all right
let's see let's do it
hopefully i don't disappoint you danny
[Laughter]
okay
so what are they saying in the chat
i'm just saying hi please choose me you
guys want to shout out some people
um
yeah give me somebody to shout out
um
so who's who likes pina coladas
oh darn it
ronnie menashe
ronnie menashe
my man ronnie what does ronnie like
uh the beast 2.0 wants a shout out
the beast where's the beast 1.0 okay
does he know about beast wars or is that
like my old reference coming in
uh
art bomb inc
what's good
all right so this person doesn't look
like
super happy but like
i don't know i'm kind of into that
very a moody picture when i chose this
picture i didn't realize her tongue was
so prominent in it i feel like i just
went for the i was like oh she's winking
but now i have to like draw this tongue
to look like a tongue
shout out
coco ken coco can coco can
all right i'm just gonna go straight to
thanks to try to finish this
let's so what does danny like
does is danny even on the chat
okay
i feel like i want to draw
let's see i'm gonna get this to be a
little bit thicker
so jason what are you what have you been
up to how's life you know life is okay
i saw spider-man which was like the
dopest thing ever oh i still haven't
seen spider-man yet
what would you rate it
like as far as like in the other
spider-man movies uh
yes no like to citizen kane being like a
10 oh just to citizen beverly hills
chihuahuas
zero
oh my god spider-man rank i i if
citizen kane is like number one though
uh i mean if the citizen kane is a 10
then this is a
this is
oh why is citizen kane you need to be
the same
i just want a more challenging rating
system for you yeah
oh i liked it a lot
i'll say that much
i don't know if it's a citizen kane but
it was like an increase
oh oh no oh my god okay spoiler it's not
as good as citizen kane oh so i can't
talk about any of the cameos from like
the lizard
yeah or when shrek shows up in the third
act that was weird yeah that was crazy
yeah
i want to give drawing advice do people
have like drawing questions
sure
people ask drawing questions
i'm gonna make this tongue
a snake tongue
because that's more interesting to me
oops
yeah
yeah teach me how to draw brent okay
this is actually brent's drawing
drawing class 101
we're going to learn some things today
so how long have you been drawing brent
i've been drawing my whole darn life
yeah i can tell you that much
um so
i'm gonna go ahead and say about 27
years oh my god you're 27.
i am 27.
what about you jason how long have you
been drawing um i've been drawing uh
my entire life as well kind of i took a
long break
which i regret
yeah um
yeah i took a long break when i fell in
love with writing
oh man yeah i fell in love writing
writing mistress writing
was crazy
don't cheat on drawing with writing kids
yeah stick to drawing oh
but writing was like the love
of mine
yeah
jason is a crazy talented
writer in addition to an artist and it
actually makes me very jealous
oh thank you for that so i'm very
resentful of him
i hope that comes through in the show
um i've got a question for you oh give
me the question dalia goolsbee dalia
goolsbee uh how do you settle or find a
drawing style
dalia ghoulsby asks how to settle or
find a drawing style all right jason you
take part one okay and then i'll
i'll come in for part two
i
try style coming from the person that
that really doesn't have a very specific
drawing style i i draw what i love
and then i i kind of let the fun that
i'm having like dictate where i'm gonna
go
yeah i draw i i personally draw to relax
like
that's my that's my drawing style i when
i go home
and i'm like done writing something and
i want to do something
do something else is when like i draw um
because uh people like brent get to draw
for a living
uh he
he develops like an awesome style
you know um but i'm i'm more style
though
yeah i i draw like comic book type style
yeah but it's because that's like what i
love you know yeah i love reading comic
books a lot so like
that that kind of like gets ingrained
into me
yeah
um
so
okay so for my style i think
so it was interesting when i was in
school we didn't exercise where we had
to do an animation we had to get through
500 sheets of paper like an entire ream
in 20 minutes
and so you got so you basically just
didn't have time to think about any of
the drawings you were doing
and so what that exercise does is it's
sort of like prevent it circumvents like
you thinking about what you're drawing
and all you have time for is just like
trying to get as many drawings done as
possible
and i think that's a good exercise
because
your style is just sort of what you do
when you're just sort of zoned out not
thinking about drawing
um
and you know just like
practicing like your basic stuff like
your
your figures like your human figures
practicing drawing animals landscapes
all your meat and potatoes
like drawing
art school stuff
that stuff's going to teach you
like
you know how to draw things well but
then your style's just going to come out
naturally you don't have to like
i don't think you have to really force a
style like you'll just sort of gravitate
towards what you want to do you know
would you say that's been your
experience jason yeah
yeah i'll definitely draw something and
someone will go that definitely looks
like a jason pierre drawing yeah and
i'll go thank you
[Music]
from rebel of the woods ooh rebel of the
woods jason this you might have some
help for this one it's how hard is it to
make the transition from drawing on a
flat table with pen and paper to drawing
on a tablet extremely hard it's
it's very hard to make the transition
from drawing on uh on a paper pen and
paper to drawing on a tablet for me
personally um i really like drawing on
pen and paper and it feels more organic
and the messiness of
of the pencil under it and the eraser
that all feels like organic and fun to
me
you know and then when you get when you
get the uh
when you get on the tablet
uh the drawing on glass
feels hard for me or drawing on plastic
it feels weird so i'm always like trying
to catch up and trying to like
find my place
but like things like like this wacom or
even like the ipad uh
make it like
easier to make that transition
and
if you just keep
keep drawing like keep doing it over and
over and over all of a sudden it starts
to like feel better um
so yeah
that's what i'll say on that
yeah just
yeah i don't know
i guess just like it's just another
practice thing like you'll just get
better over time yeah um you just kind
of have to hit your head against the
wall long enough to
get better at it
diana lou is asking us how to draw hair
um okay so
this is another thing i kind of got
better at in art school so if you want
to draw hair
um i guess i can break it more down in
my next drawing if you stick around but
hair you have to think about less as the
individual hairs and more about the
volume of the hair so just try to like
squint your eyes when you're looking at
somebody's hair and say like okay what
is like the shape of their hair
you know like because everybody's hair
has got sort of a general shape
depending on how they like combed it or
if it's like falling down even even hair
that's like curly or whatever sort of
has like
a volume to it and that's the most
important thing to get for hair
um
i'll kind of
i'll explain that a bit more on my next
drawing if you want to
stick around for that
i think i'm almost done with this one
yeah i kind of like this
yeah okay
[Laughter]
i will tell you one thing for sure is
that everybody on the planet has hard
time with hands like the most prolific
artists you know still
are like annoyed having to draw hands
um
what do you what do you think jason or
you're pretty good at drawing hands
terrible
terrible um
which you see from the previous episodes
i'm terrible at drawing hands
but i i that's another thing like i take
a long time to draw so
if i were at home i'd be drawing
something for like hours yeah and uh
which gives you time to like perfect
the hands yeah or perfect the thing that
you're drawing trying to yeah so
that's what i'll say on that
okay um
so i'm done with this one
oh i need to like move on to another one
but
okay
that one is done
okay so i'm gonna do another person
we're gonna go over hair
and everybody's gonna learn a thing
okay so whoever i chose has the coolest
hair and that's why i picked them
okay i see a lot of cats
a lot of oh demons okay
oh my god so these are scary
okay
okay i like the girl with the
multi-colored hair
oh well
okay okay cool i found one so
i'm gonna do this girl with the glasses
her name is
uh
wynn i believe
and her tag is
transparent joy
and i guess it's tricky because i can't
like i can't
this is on my phone so i can't show you
the picture of the girl so basically
she's got her hair sort of combed and
then to the back
um and this is like a good example of
this because
like you can see a lot of the individual
hairs kind of being combed back so like
a lot of the time if you're starting out
drawing you might draw the hair like
you know you're drawing each hair like
this
around the person's
head
and that's a pretty like
inefficient way
to draw hair so i'm going to show you
how i would go about it
it's like here's the head
i'm gonna get the basic hair shape down
i'm gonna go to another one
and see who i can
choose
okay
so i got the basic like
framework down okay so i'm going to go
over the hair so
she's got sort of this like quaffed hair
so drawing which one uh this one's
transparent joy she uploaded it like a
little while ago all right if you can
find it
um
she's sort of got like
i see a few i'm just sort of drawing the
shape of the quaffed like across her
hair
i think i want to do
matthew chow
matthew chow i think i'm gonna do
matthew john cool all right matthew get
ready
so yeah so here i just sort of drew a
few lines like volume lines to sort of
get the direction just imply the
direction the hair is going
um
and my first line i drew was this sort
of line down here to sort of show which
direction all the hair was going to be
flowing so you'll see that even though
there's like a lot of individual hairs
and it looks confusing
it's you can find like
where they're all going
like judging by like the part or
wherever they comb their hair
that's usually pretty the most useful
way to go about it
i like this picture of him in the
the blanket
okay
one thing i like to do for eyelashes too
is
the more like when you draw a lot of
eyelashes it can tend to look kind of
creepy if you like draw too many like
individual eyelashes so like a cheap
trick that like i think anime does this
a lot they'll just sort of like
darken like the area with a lot of like
eyelashes so like
you got like the rim of their eye here
and i'll just like make that darker and
that'll just sort of imply eyelashes
versus like
drawing the individual ones like that
i just think it can look a little bit
cleaner
okay
okay i'm liking this image more
i tried to draw a serpent the first time
um so i'm gonna like be a little less
ambitious with this one oh
um jason's always always super
super duper ambitious
am i i hope so i hope so dude that
minion you drew still blows my mind oh
thank you i can't get over it
okay here's this person
okay sorry i'm trying to get through a
lot so i'm just gonna like go straight
to
straight to color on this one i hope you
like the
line work as is
[Music]
do we have any more drawing questions
how hard
destroyer wants to know on a scale of
one to ten i like these scales yeah so
yeah how hard is it to draw hands
um
[Music]
okay
let's say
what's it for you jason how hard is it
to draw hands i put i put hands up there
like
with uh
i'll put hands at like
a seven
a seven that's pretty hard and pretty
hard i'm going to be honest jason that's
pretty hard
um
[Music]
i think seven's about good
seven it depends on which hand because
you get used to drawing hands a lot
depending on like if you animate or you
draw a lot then
there tend to be like hands you get
really good at drawing like fists and
like fingers pointing but like hands
that are like facing the camera are
always like really tricky
um
just hands doing bizarre things
just are always going to be hard to do
um
yeah i like if it if i'm like again if
i'm drawing like
um
at home and i'm like i have time yeah
and i have time to like perfect said
hand
then it's more of like
oh okay let me let me like really dig
into this yeah but if i'm like if i have
to just like speed draw hands i am they
are they look jacked up oh
yeah yeah i'm about to speed your hands
to surrender that is
that is that is absolutely fair
hands are no joke i'll draw them like a
fist you know yeah that's the one thing
i like about portraiture is like there
don't tend to be a lot of hands involved
um i forgot somebody wanted us to draw
hands though i guess we should probably
get on that
um
i'll think of i'll find one with like
somebody's hand in it
i think the the hardest thing for me is
drawing color
is adding color or coloring period yeah
color is hard yeah
i grew up just doing pen and ink
yeah that's it i wanted to be um a
penciler
for comic books when i was a kid yeah um
so i didn't practice coloring yeah i was
just like oh one day i'll just hire
really
you know
sad person to do this coloring for yeah
but now like as an adult like no i
actually have to do it i have to you
know and with with tablets being
ubiquitous like every artist is coloring
their own stuff and yeah in comic books
you'll see something will say
instead of saying like uh penciller and
inker it'll just say artist
yeah
yeah they don't even get a colorist
anymore all right i'm saying this one's
done
yeah that one's good
this one is um
transparent
joy
okay next one i promise it'll be a hand
one
we're gonna we're gonna get a handle on
it
um
okay
okay i think i'm doing this guy justice
until i add uh color so i start
recording
uh we're gonna wait for jason okay
yeah okay okay
this guy's holding up a hand
i'm not crazy about the picture let's
see
oh i like that the guy here is holding
up his phone
like
um okay i'm gonna draw this dude
he's holding up his phone but like
i wanna make his hand do something else
so this guy
is oh darn it where'd he go
dang it
okay
joshua joshua clinton
all things switch so this guy looks like
a switch
nintendo switch man
do they all have to be colored
that's probably up to your discretion
okay
okay so this guy's all things switch and
instead of
his hand holding a phone i'm gonna draw
him holding a switch
because that looks like his brand
all right matthew so i think i did a
good job with your
your the your the outline like your face
um and i will come back to
color you
completely another day
but
for now i think your spare time
you'll draw him in your spare time when
you go home yeah when i go home i will
like practice on you matthew
and
no i'm just i'm just joking
okay
so i'm gonna draw everything but the
hand and then we'll get to the hand
how i'm doing it
yep
through your messy hair
so he's gonna like hold it
like this probably
i'm gonna fudge this a bit okay
i'm looking for
the paintball the paintbucket tool i
can't find it the paint bucket tool
so jason you going to comic-con no i
wish
jason can you take me to comic-con
um
nope
there we go i'm gonna go to the next one
i was like where is that tool jesus
christ
this shows you how much i don't use um
photoshop
um i love to draw at home
uh
yeah i just like to draw at home on pen
and paper
that is where i live
all right so this guy's gonna be holding
his switch up just kind of like he's
holding his phone up but it's a switch
now um okay so
this part
that's gonna be the hand so
we're gonna do the fun artist thing of
breaking things down into simple easy to
do shapes
so this is gonna be like
this part of the hand
right here and then from there i like to
just sort of like extrapolate the
fingers
so we're gonna have one finger
up here
and then another thing you can do is
sort of group together fingers to make
it look
like a little more uniform and less
crazy
um
just like a more simple shape like this
and just split up the fingers like that
start defining like the palm muscle
i like the creepy picture that someone
named emily posted someone named emily
uh the it's like a picture of her with a
printed out man's face on it
it's pretty interesting that's pretty
creepy yeah
um
someone's begging me to draw a shark
with lips on it with human lips on it
i think you better indulge them jason oh
my god i don't know what i would do with
that one i think i would do it i you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna pass on that oh
i was i was counting on you to do that
oh my god
oh my god
i think these are getting creepier and i
love it
all right so i got the basic outline got
his hand down
yeah so like this method you can kind of
use for all kinds of hands like an open
hand
you just start off with like
this sort of like trapezoid looking
shape
so
get the thumb muscle in there
sort of get the
basic finger shape down
which kind of looks like that
start drawing out your fingies
so i'm gonna do
uh
one two three four derrick
i'm gonna do derek silver
if i can get his handle in here there we
go
you can sort of draw the palm
there's like a hand sort of
yeah
you can make a point
just by moving the other fingers in
that's kind of gross but if i had more
time
i would make that a pretty hand
i think i chose another person with
because of his hair is interesting the
way it's coming out the top of his hat
but i'll see what i can do with it
basically uh
record an episode draw
some
all right so
we are going to record an episode of
draw off now
um
which camera is recording oh yeah we're
over here
there are a lot of cameras on this side
just so you all know there are one two
three and then two eyes four eyes
staring at us judging us actually
and everybody at home and everyone at
home judging along with
them guys
yeah i'm ready
all right i'm recording i'm recording
here we
good this go bfb 58 4222 draw
live scene two alpha take one a mark
b mark
c mark
all right
you guys pause real quick and uh
hi i'm jason and brent to your specific
cameras and then jason say uh today we
are drawing uh profile pictures
submitted
uh
during a live stream
all right hey i'm jason
hey i'm brent and today we're drawing
profile pictures submitted during a live
stream
live live super duper live yeah
you wanted to see how hard it was in
real time
this is it this is it you guys get a
peek behind the curtain yeah so
congratulations
so go ahead and introduce yourself like
here uh jason said like i've chosen
silver 888 yeah i've i've chosen dm
silver 889
and i've chosen all things switch
um
at all things switch
i'm giving him a switch in his hand i
can't exactly remember what a switch
looks like right now
so i'm just gonna write switch on the
back of this
i have his picture in my hand so i know
what he looks like i'm just hoping that
my drawing comes out
looking like what he looks like
i'm usually like hunched over in the
living room drawing at home
that's like my my natural your natural
state of being yeah
all right all things switch liner is
dunzo so now for some color
[Music]
so jason what's your approach to taking
someone's photo and
drawing it
i mean i'm trying to just make it look
human first
um i think in the first one the first
one i did i was just like let me get
creative and try to make her
into a like a serpent lady because she
was sticking her tongue out and then i
was worried that it was like so far away
that it like didn't have her essence
anymore
um so right now i'm just like let's try
to draw them
decent first yeah
let me try to get them decently first
yeah i'm going like a little stylized
but i think for the most part i'm trying
to just like
nail down who they are yeah i don't know
people get annoyed with me in real life
when i draw them like way too weird
which i like to do yeah they're like it
doesn't look like me you look like it's
like that's not the point it's not a
photograph man yeah
you want it to look like you take a
selfie i know just take a selfie darn it
okay yeah this guy is taking a selfie in
his picture
that'd be great if i just drew his
selfie
as a selfie
yeah okay
okay time to do the switch
jason what's your favorite video game
did you ask me that on purpose yes i
don't play video games
jason
oh my god
we rehearsed this
um i uh my favorite video game is sonic
the hedgehog yeah that's right yeah
literally i love sonic the hedgehog um
but like
it's just so old it's like the only
thing on my phone
yeah i told someone that before and then
they looked at my phone and there were
like five different versions of sonic
that i had downloaded like wow you were
not lying when you said you liked that
game
you really do love sonic you love sonic
who doesn't love sonic though yeah
if anyone wants me to draw them as a
hedgehog like i am so down i would love
to see that happen i am so down that or
shrek
i'll do anything for a good shrek
drawing
okay
all right all things switch i'm saying
you're just about done
here you go
show this to your friends and family
show it to no one
hide it in shame
uh
whatever you want to do
uh oh wait you have like some facial
hair oh i'm sorry dude i shaved your guy
i shaved you i'm sorry okay hold on
um i'm going to give you
i don't know i kind of like my drawing
of view without without the stash i'm
just going to keep it all right
you saved him
i'm sorry oh i also took off his glasses
oh my god i'm a terrible person
this isn't him at all all right i'll
give him his glasses that's the least i
could do for him
i feel like we're so close now i've i've
just been watching your face so
intimately
i really you know what i really like
drawing for faces is the glasses and
stuff
i feel like that grounds faces like so
easily like with such minimal effort
yeah okay that's done
all right
so this is
all
things switch
okay
let's do
another one
okay
got some very weird oh wait this one's
so cool which one
hold on
this person okay so julia
julia denz or something he's like out in
the snow
she looks like she's like freezing her
butt off look at this one oh that's a
great picture isn't that fun yeah okay
i'm doing this one sorry i don't know
how to pronounce your last name but i
like this picture
okay
yeah take
take pictures in like weird extreme
climates that's fine
but be safe
or or you know don't no yeah pc
[Laughter]
okay so this girl
she's got like her hair is it like tied
at the bottom it looks like she has like
a beard or like the most intense mutton
chops in the world i want to see it
again look at what she did
yeah it's pretty this adult that's a
dope picture it is a dope picture though
okay so i'm gonna yeah i really like
this so here we go
all right i'm taking a very long time
sorry y'all i will i will like now speed
up
now that i've got his face to look like
a face
what are the comments saying
people people
you gotta post it on twitter with the
hashtag
drawflive if you want us to do you okay
did another person i think this looks
just like him now
all right sg wants to know was there a
certain character style you love when
you were little
is asking if there is a certain style or
character
um sg is asking if there is a certain
style or character that inspired us to
draw like a certain way yeah yeah so
what what about you jason oh i had a few
uh
let's hear it i grew up in the in that
you know early comic book
age of the you know the 90s uh saw jim
lee
todd mcfarlane
um
a lot of those even
mark silvestri
a lot of the image comics guys my
favorite artist is damien scott he's a
jamaican comic book artist he does like
really wild um
graffiti-esque superhero work and drew
on
batman batgirl for a while yeah and his
just his style just
stood out and looked unique yeah i
really like people with styles that like
don't look like
what's out there like if this if the
style looks
like it came out of nowhere yeah and
it's not like being widely used i'm a
really big fan of that yeah so a lot of
those i spent like my early childhood
years
copying a lot of them
um
and just like pouring over all those
lines yeah dude
i did a lot of that when i was younger
and then uh until i got brave enough to
be like i'm just going to draw it on my
own
yeah and i drew a lot of uh spider-man
when i was a kid oh yeah spider-man had
the coolest poses yeah drawing like
they're so acrobatic and dynamic yeah
yeah i love that i love spider-man so
you know my style i really love for
comic books is mike mignola
oh yeah hellboy
god his stuff is so sick looking
it's super unique for
like action comic books
yeah
and he uses like negative space really
well oh yeah like he uses so much black
and all these drawings but like it just
yeah just creates such an amazing
composite graphic composition
so dm silver i think this looks like you
yeah it's not going to look like you
once i put color in should we switch
wait let's switch for these i want to
see your picture okay you want to switch
go ahead oh wait no no should we sit we
should finish and then we'll switch
yeah we'll finish and then we'll switch
okay i love this girl's hair i'm gonna
make her head way bigger so i can
emphasize his hair
okay
any more questions in the meantime
yeah jenny vanderpass also loves mike
mignola yeah let's do it she's got good
taste i'm gonna save this
mary elizabeth what's the hardest part
mary elizabeth wants to know what's the
hardest hardest part about um what a
face to draw
um
hmm what would you say jason um
i think like so faces are not that hard
it's like expressive faces
yeah you know like getting a particular
expression yeah that's that's like what
i feel is hard like
and especially like i can from drawing
from pictures is fine
but like when you have to
to
[Music]
make someone look like they're conveying
a specific emotion or reactions reacting
to something and then not making their
eyes look like they're dead yeah you
know yeah that's true so that's like um
a thing that i have issues with yeah
yeah i'd say that's definitely like the
biggest part is like just drawing a face
straight up like you know
i feel like a lot we always gravitate
towards drawing faces so that's usually
not too hard yeah but then when it comes
to like
drawing yeah like a particular like
weird expression like that somebody's
doing like to really really capture what
that looks like
takes a lot of time and like effort for
sure
let's see who else can i draw
in here
ultra miller roblox wants to know have
you noticed a large improvement from
looking at your old drawings
no uh sorry what was the name cultural
of roblox
neutral noah roblox
ultra noah roblox wants to know if we
see a big improvement between our
drawing now and drawing
before like at the start of the show
like at the beginning if you if you're
asking me
hell yeah
but it's not like it's not like like i
became better at drawing is i just got
started getting used to using
the the tablet the tablet you know yeah
um i like i said i'm obviously not uh i
don't draw on
tablets at home
uh so
yeah that that first
jiminy cricket jesus christ
that was awesome shut up that was my
favorite drawing
one of my favorites that in the
spongebob and minion
minion spongebob too many cricket that's
my top three jason drawings oh my god i
was just like but spongebob was badass
it was jiminy cracker was just so out
there the jiminy cricket was just like
so weird what am i doing right now
well i was about to put justin's whole
name all i need is his handle
[Laughter]
what is exactly
at yo
or you justin
what cult is this that he has on his
shirt
a cult he's a cult oh should i be
drawing i don't know or the guy with a
cult on his shirt maybe not
maybe i'll just get to this yes
he just has a great picture of his face
okay i like this girl a lot i'll do a
really fast one
whoever julia is she's getting a nice
skittlecoat cause it looks cold on his
shirt talking about i think he's fine
all right let's
i'll try to do one really fast
[Laughter]
buzzfeed promotes cults
that's what's good life's gonna be
oh my god yeah that's gonna be the
thumbnail called question mark old
question mark
uh i actually i also really like the
hair on this one because it also kind of
shows like you know
just the volume of the hair is like this
main kind of thing
yeah i really like this picture a lot
and then we're going to switch jason are
you onto a different one or you oh i i
already went
okay
well i'm barely into the second one so
yeah
all right i'll try to do one more i'll
show you this one i really like this one
but then i'll try to do another one
in the time that we have
i would say just finish that one just
finish this one all right
never mind i'm sorry people
good news is jackie's coming on
[Laughter]
jackie's gonna do some sick drawings
yeah
[Laughter]
i feel like i'm drawing conan o'brien
that's what this is looking like it's
looking like conan o'brien
all right i mean this girl looks like
super freaked out in this picture all
right
i'm gonna take it back a little bit
all right
and now it's time for
soon coloring
yeah this looks absolutely nothing like
this guy i'm drawing conan o'brien
[Laughter]
just draw conan o'brien man and this guy
he looks nothing like conan o'brien oh
that's the irony of this drawing
well you know what
who doesn't want to look like conan
that's what i've always known
is it difficult
it is it it it is what's it is it
difficult to draw likenesses
it is it is very difficult to draw
likenesses it's fun to an extent um
sometimes when people ask me to draw
them i'm like i'll draw a bad version of
you so it turns out good it's like oh
you did a good job
[Laughter]
you gotta put expectations really low
yeah
um
yeah but then it's like you see the
people that draw the like at state fairs
and stuff that do the caricatures yeah
and they'll be like very exaggerated but
they'll look you'll in your mind you'll
go oh my god it looks exactly like them
yeah even though they're super
exaggerated
caricature art is pretty tricky
i think
okay
okay
and jason you make movies too don't you
oh my god are we plugging
i'm just saying you are a multi-talented
man you do writing i do raw oh yeah you
direct
i do the man does it all
that's all i'm saying if y'all want to
see some stuff
like that existential donut
i mean
you don't have to give them exactly the
thing but i'm just saying
i hope people like their drawings yeah
are the people who were drawing like are
you all in the stream commenting
are they reacting to what we're drawing
of them
oh really what do they think
like them okay oh okay okay uh doodles
by potato wants to know how do you
improve in digital art
so doodles by potato is asking how do
you improve in digital art
um it's all you brent
so i got this when i was i got my first
like drawing tablet for the computer
when i was in high school
um it's definitely like a it's a
different experience because the surface
is a lot smoother than like drawing on
paper
uh and yeah just like overall feels a
bit different but
you know like
it doesn't
like i'd say like
first of all avoid the soft round brush
like the plague which is this one wait
the one that makes this fuzzy line like
i
i don't know any i honestly don't know
any professional artists that like
primarily use that one
um
i would stick at least when you're
starting out with just like hard round
brush
like you know pen
pen pressure
uh so you can make your lines thinner
and thicker and maybe like a little bit
of transfer so like your opacity changes
as you draw
so like see the line kind of disappears
as as i um
as i do as i get lighter on it and
that's honestly it like just use one
brush
on whatever program you're doing and do
all of your art and that one brush paint
all your textures in that brush do all
your lighting and shading in that brush
uh erase with that brush just do
everything because like and literally do
that for like
i'm not kidding like do that for like
years like you it takes a long time
just getting used to that to be able to
then move on to like
pretty texture brushes like something
like this
like that like the line looks nice but
like that's not going to make your art
any better
and it'll just show even more like
your
lack of ability if you're using these
like fancy brushes
um
but like the drawings still aren't
looking as good so i would say stick
with one brush
and just like
make it like a really basic brush and
just stick with that and then do all of
your drawings
um
sort of with that for a while and then
once you get really confident and you're
obviously like kicking butt
then feel free to
to move on
julia denny's oh my god dude i love your
picture this thing is so cool
i like that you're just freezing your
butt off
like like did you take this picture like
for this or was this an actual like
like just picture you had on hand
because i think this is this picture is
awesome
did she respond
or is she just lost in the maybe she's
maybe you got lost i'm sorry i don't
expect you to like actually get back to
that yeah
um
yeah anyway
i'm glad you like it
yeah she said she was hiking a few
months ago
hiking if so julia was hiking a few
months ago
when she took this cool picture of
herself and freezed her butt off
um
so
sweet well
that's a this is a rad picture i'm glad
we got to use this
she said she just took it for fun
she just took it for fun
and now she is being watched by
legions of youtubers
as i attempt to draw it and we're all
talking to her right we're all talking
to her
so what did you have for breakfast yeah
i'm just playing
what type of music is our everyone does
everyone listen to i'm i love listening
to music while i draw oh dude yeah
yeah that's another thing yeah i like to
listen to like
movie soundtracks and stuff when i draw
yeah
what what's your jam do you like lyrics
when you draw or is that distracting i i
i love lyrics when i draw i don't do
lyrics for
um when i'm writing yeah that's the
thing when i'm doing like really
intensive like creative stuff i tend to
not like to have anything too
distracting yeah
um
but
yeah so i feel you i feel you on that
yeah i can't like because when i'm
writing it's like i'm
if if there's lyrics in it i'll like
accidentally write
one of the lyrics oh no i'll be like
because i'm like
going like this in my mind yeah you're
just going at it
so justin yo justin
yeah let's let's swap wanna you wanna
see we gotta do the
the draw off thing which is to like swap
pictures right yeah okay i'm done with
this one all right now we're gonna swap
wait wait wait wait give me a second oh
okay okay oh it's already four oops oh
no
okay jackie and kevin are up next
let me just save this
i don't even know how many it did
jason
okay you ready oh okay okay we can swap
all right
no rules there's no rules it's live
we're doing it live okay
all right so i cover my eyes cover your
eyes
okay
let's reveal oh snap it's justin
this is a great picture
oh dang i want to see your where's your
reference picture for this dude um i
like your stubble on him it is
oh i left my phone over there right here
oh yeah yeah oh it's a fan cult oh you
got him though yeah this is him that's
him yeah yeah okay okay okay yeah yeah
you guys face shape right
yeah
yeah this is very very accurate you
nailed it this is a great
drawing thanks dude yeah yours is dope
too julia you lucked out with brent
justin
you are the proud owner of this jason
jason original
i want to look at your other ones i
think they're all in that photoshop file
okay i'm going to switch back let me
just click over them oh
how do you look at your other ones oh
i think they're all just in the
um did you guys do final thoughts you
were sitting there so there's one oh
that was great
uh
no that's up but you saved them all
that's cool oh god
okay there's that guy wow switch oh i
only did three
okay whatever those are all great thank
you um
okay yeah
let me put
your where are your inks for your life
there we go yeah so uh any final
thoughts on
uh drawing likenesses
um
it's hard and you get self-conscious oh
sorry so thoughts on drawing people's
likeness um
it's hard you get self-conscious because
you're worried about what the person
because it's so personal yeah you're
drawing a person
i feel like you just get so
self-conscious that you're gonna like
mess up and like not do justice to their
face yeah yeah
i think that what my thing was like like
i said before i was trying to have fun
with the first one but it didn't feel
like it was that woman anymore yeah
so then for the rest of them i was just
trying to get as close to them as
possible after that yeah um
yeah and i feel like if i had more time
then i could like get it as close to
them as i could and when it was there
then i would have fun yeah
you should have had an hour for each one
of these pictures yeah sometimes
life be like that yeah
all right
okay
yeah but i'm taking it
and jackie's not even here to say
anything about it
all right
so i'm gonna
save this picture
i have two bars
um
should i stop recording
yeah
switch back over to photoshop
oh no i did four okay
oh i thought i only did three drawings
but i did four
okay
uh cool all right we will take your mic
all right yeah
it's been real guys yeah this was fun
now i want to read over the comments to
see how much people were judging me
people were just saying maybe
oh okay yeah literally
90
yeah
how many uh how many bars you got on
that bike jacket everything
listen they want to see how the sausage
is made this is how we make the sausage
quick someone someone say their social
security number
oh i have the mic now don't worry i
forgot that yes
i'm slowly understanding how this works
am i in front of a camera right now no
right
okay
i'm hiding things i'm hiding a lot of
illegal substances
all right
is that okay to say we're currently
waiting for jackie
to put on your microphone and join us
your snapchat got ruined brent what are
you going to do about it live
whatever
live wait did my what
how do i make the chair big
there you go
all right
the champ is here
[Laughter]
where's the camera
we're only for the live stream we're
only on the main cam sure yeah
oh well that's not a us problem seems
like a them problem
just
oh look at all these these are all great
look at these oh is this a new file just
for me let's yeah let's do them 1200 by
1200.
all right
okay that's pretty neat
and uh
and when you start drawing uh write the
username across the top real big
correct in fact in fact i'm gonna
gonna make a type layer with the
people's username oh you're getting
fancy with the layers fancy jackie i'm
not gonna do any of that hey should we
introduce ourselves no come on
right there to the main camera hi
internet
you're making me look like a chump i
thought i didn't know the order i
thought you were going to say hey
internet i'm kevin and then
i don't okay there's no cutting there's
no cutting this is 100 live this is how
it works hi internet i'm kevin hi
internet i'm jackie i don't know how to
record
and welcome to draw off live the final
hour uh we are drawing your profile
pictures all you have to do is tweet a
selfie or a picture of your pet or
something weird with the hashtag drawoff
live
and we will choose ones to draw here
live for you with
our hands with our hands and eyes
working together side by side yes
yes do i just look it up on my
little phone yeah on your little phone
okay what's the hashtag draw off live
okay
okay that sounds easy enough huh
uh do we wanna do we wanna shout out
some some people while we're waiting i
shout out kevin
bye jason bye brent bye jason bye
friends yes everybody say bye internet
say goodbye draw me draw me draw me draw
me draw me me me me me me
i just pick like a random person yep
choose whoever you want okay
who are you choosing i don't know i
haven't looked yet well can you hurry it
up we only have an hour no we only have
an hour so
we got to get jamming
set the chat um fire oh boy
me me me draw me drunk how am i supposed
to know which me is you okay you guys oh
you guys are so silly you guys are such
silly little beans
i'm not gonna draw bobby hill who did
that
oh okay this is the first one that came
up and i'm gonna draw this one wait i'm
also i was also wait make sure yours is
not the same as mine oh okay all right i
just look it i just show me it it's i'm
gonna do this guy
that guy huh yeah i love that because uh
so i'm gonna do a nurse nurselin
ibrahimov i apologize if i said that
wrong
his uh handle is norike 22. oh my god
i'm going to draw this one he said he
said ps garfield was the best so he gets
my
folks i'm going to draw
at
i like that i also wrote that kind of
weird write it yeah write it big across
the top all right right across the top
here we go oh boy
enrique
it's your time to shine baby nat
shout out
i don't know what to say oh you know
what i gotta get my glove on why is the
resolution so whack what do you mean i
don't know because we're going out to
the streaming oh
so it's their fault yeah it's the
internet's fault you guys just asked for
so much and we have so little
all right i only have several pennies
um so give us some uh give us some
people to shout out what is quito says
kevin the legend is here oh
you're such a legend not a legend
you're a legend come on
who else
i'm going super cartoony with these i'm
just going to draw it like without a
sketch so sorry wow
i'm trying to get as many done as i can
isn't that the point i hear that
let's uh let's say goodnight to
beautiful who's got to go to bed now oh
good night good night beautiful
thank you for joining us i didn't like
that weird yeah that was not all right
that was a little you take that back
yeah i take that back apologize to
everybody here
sorry beautiful
sorry
why did you have to say it like that
duchess of
dinos says i adore kevin and oh duchess
of dinos thank you so much dinosaurs are
pretty neat they died a long time ago
though did you know that
i hope you i hope i wasn't the one to
break that team boy
all right
enrique has got a great smile oh he does
have a great friend i'm trying to
capture it as fast as i can
um am i supposed to be saying what i'm
drawing or am i just
going okay
talk talk to me
jackie stop being
wacky just stop it
getting wacky with kevin and jackie
i wish i could leave
i'm just kidding kevin i'm having a
great time
i'm having a wonderful time and you're
already complaining about that i'm not
complaining about anything
i've never complained in my life and
that is a fact that is not true at all
um i'm drawing i don't i guess this is
them
they wrote corn and tomato in the tweet
so i'm not gonna draw the avocado sorry
there's like a lot of people in this
image
um but it's just a little boy dressed up
as a tomato
we're little girls sorry i don't know
all right i'm already on inks on my
first one
you are in a tomato i can't tell we're
doing it jackie
we're doing it as fast as we can i'm
trying you're giving me a lot of
pressure now
my birthday was just the other day my
birthday was also just the other day
july 5th when's july 9th oh my god we
should fight
we should fight on stream we should
fight to the death and whoever uh
whoever wins gets to have their birthday
next year yeah because the other person
will be dead no we're not fighting to
the death jackie we always want to fight
to the death and i'm not going to do it
that's not true i don't always want to
fight to the dead
i usually want to fight to the death
because that makes it more fun
sorry
i like fighting
oh so you're a fellow cancer baby like
me i'm a little baby
i mean we are super sensitive
or so i've been told by other people i
guess so
i mean you do cry
a lot in these videos no i don't jackie
if you guys wait the future videos kevin
cries a whole lot don't cry cries he's
like i can't draw this character i'm
having a bad time
all right i don't know what's going on
in this drawing but i've drawn it and
i'm not going back so
there's no going back this is live am i
coloring this
probably
i'm just going to do it
why not right so it looks like my man
enrique
is
skiing
he's a skier
jackie you've ever been skiing i'm
really gassy right now
cool
cool i mean i'm just i don't want to
burp in the mic right that's
probably not great please don't okay
i'll try but there's no promise to share
this space with you oh that's true it's
really hot in here i don't know if you
guys know these monitors generate quite
a lot of
artistic heat and we have to have the
air conditioning off yeah because you
guys are going to be looking for the
sound quality is so low i can't hear
what kevin and jackie are saying
that's not what you can try i'm sorry
i'm no i'm saying can we try turning the
ac on
and see if it is see if everybody hates
it
yeah i know it's bad okay but
i know it's bad so kevin
enough of your suggestion
oh if it's bad no it's okay we'll live
we'll live
um
i have to sneeze
i'm doing just heads
that wasn't an answer to him like what
did you what did you say no it's all
fine
the moments passed
the moment has passed
all right
okay i drew and they want the ac
ac if you want the ac put a smiley face
in the chat okay
i want to see smiley faces all around
and if you hate ac
here's the thing put the letter w here's
the smiley face or w
we're gonna if we turn on the ac you
guys can't complain about the sound
that's not gonna that's you're not gonna
stop anybody they're still gonna
complain aren't they yeah
oh my gosh whoever was on this computer
last messed up all my wonderful
hot keys
okay here you go net and el mundo i hope
you like it i really like that you guys
are in funny little costumes did you
finish one already i mean i'm not really
sketching
and it's not a fantastic drawing if i'm
being honest with you
i did i just paint bucketed it did it
wow okay next
going up next
going up next oh i'm going to draw this
one
i'm going to draw you
i'm going to draw you because you
hashtagged it in all caps which is
frightening it feels like
you really want this more than other
people
um
i'm going to say it wrong bower victoria
i'm gonna draw you because you look nice
in this photo you're very cute i like
your little sweater it seems like it's
winter
i can't actually no it's
i don't know the concept of weather
because
i live in california yeah it's i don't
know what that is
okay
uh jw cool boy
jw cool boy
how do you draw like facial hair or
mustache or beard is there any tips
tips for uh what's his name
jw jw jw cool boy oh sorry jw come on
my man jw cool boy wants to know how do
we draw facial hair just draw facial
hair just do it are the worst at drawing
tips you just gotta do it you don't know
how to draw it so you draw it
all right and then one day one day
you'll be good at it
uh if you were watching brent earlier he
was talking about um
basically thinking of hair as like a
single piece
with its own shape and so that's how i
think about facial hair
um
just as its own kind of entity
see
see what happens when you're helpful i
guess what are you saying we're still
talk okay jw cool boy
cool guy
all right i am done with norik
22. you know what drawing a real person
much harder
than uh yeah drawing a cartoon from
memory yeah just letting you all know
all right
who is next
why does it make the chat blow up
me me me me no me no me no me me me me
you
you you
you see let's see
oh my gosh
i don't know if you guys know but
drawing is just drawing the same line
over and over
in a different configuration just
drawing it over and over until one of
the lines is better than the other line
can you hear the ac
smiley face is in the chat for yes
so we have to apologize together
for making them sweat
all right let's see who we got let's see
who we got those brave soldiers who's
next
who do i like
who do i
like say it like that
your eyes kind of covered miss
victoria but i'm gonna do work with it
you know
okay
i got one
i got one you got one i got one you got
one i am going to do morgan ray
who is that morgan ray
that's a good one and
yeah because she has
two colored hair which is kind of cool
that's pretty that's pretty neat
yeah
okay you can't really tell but that's
her hand you know what i'll redo it i'll
redo this part i don't know why i
started with it
morgan ray here we go
morgan i'm going super fast
so hope you like it
sounded like you were giving up
what yeah what are you saying you know
the internet can hear everything i said
everything
i'm not going back
jackie what are your tips for drawing
faster
don't say just draw faster just
don't
learn
come on fast
i heard that if you drink a lot of um
caffeine
you are fast
i don't know what the tips are i don't
i've just i've been drawing for like my
whole life
so it's like you just gotta practice
you know
well i've been drawing for my whole life
too and i feel like i'm super slow okay
then draw longer than that
i'm sorry kevin don't cry not on screen
okay that's your arm it's like in a
sweater
i hope everyone understands what's
happening
oh dear
all the shortcuts are wrong
okay
i said i wouldn't scream and i think i
screamed just now now here's the
question
are these people that i'm drawing going
to end up looking like me
that's what the internet wants to know
jackie i think oh i gotta make my
thing a little brighter
um
maybe but there's nothing wrong with
that
i i would think
what if they look a little like you
that's just your own personal flair is
that
you make stuff look like you
but i don't want to be known as the guy
who can only draw himself jackie that's
literally what frida kahlo is known for
yeah frida kahlo was an amazing artist
exactly
are you saying i'm an amazing artist
yeah i think kevin is amazing she said
it live
nobody can ever say i didn't say that no
one can
please stop singing i have to stay here
for the next couple of minutes
um we're going super simple
she's got cute lips
we're doing head only
now we're moving on
i kind of
i think i messed up the shape of your
face
but i think it's cute
i hope other people think it's cute i
hope victoria thinks it's cute i opened
the wacom desktop center settings
please don't look at that
whoops now you guys all know how to
set up your wacom tablets whack them
whack them walk them walk them walk them
lock them say right i'm trying my best
uh yeah i'm almost done with this one
oh boy what
it's hard to draw this fast
it is
okay i'm done with yours
victoria
i hope you like it i'm sorry that it's
not really super accurate and i keep
messing up the layers
but i think it's pretty cute i hope you
have a good day goodbye forever
i'll never speak to you ever again
it's over
um who's next jackie i don't know oh
there goes the chat should i um
should i be drawing
real people only no right just anything
you can choose whatever you want
i can choose whatever i want to choose
i'm not gonna draw this one but shout
out to harry totter
it's just a tater tot that looks like
harry potter nice it's pretty neat uh
you already have drawn it better than me
so i feel like i can't really do it
justice i'm gonna screw this up um
i cannot keep
um i'm going to draw
i'm gonna draw chibi marie
it's gonna be like a fan art of her
drawing
okay
uh
or i think you know
marie is a feminine name they're drawing
and yes we apologize if we uh
mispronoun people yes
i don't want to do that
wait
and your username
what are they saying in the uh chat in
the old chatty chats lots of me okay
sophia gomez says who wouldn't want
kevin
well you're a kevin legend sophia gomez
if you would like a drawing that looks
like me but it's supposed to be you
then you've come to the right place
okay so i got chibi paul
lelux
i think i'm saying it she be pollux
maybe
maybe i'm oh good old chibi pollocks
yeah you know chibi polish back in the
old days me and chibi pogs would always
go to the yeah in the bowling in the
bottom
team yeah me and chibi pollock
t.b
they're good
they're great um
uh they have this really cool drawing i
think it's supposed to be of them
okay and i think it's really cool so i'm
gonna draw like a little fan art okay
chibi pollux tv pollux making it happen
making it happen live on the internet
are you supposed to be like a dog
i think you are i'm sorry if i get the
animal wrong
time i'm gonna try i'm gonna try how
much time do we have left not enough
32 minutes oh that's actually quite a
lot of minutes
that's more than i thought anyway
this character is like permanently
wearing the
the dog filter on snapchat
question for jackie from crystal perkins
oh chris crystal perkins has a question
for jack that sounds like a
parks and rec character
how did you come across your cute style
of art
uh i just drew for a really long time
and then i stopped wanting to draw like
other things
and now i just draw like this
i don't have a story it just happened ah
sorry
thanks for thinking that it's cute
shout out to crystal
perkins
sure love that person crystal perkins
crystal perkins and perkins
that's why that's why that's why okay
what a simple answer
uh
[Music]
cortland stuckey says are you guys
self-taught or did you study
uh
i
am so what's her name
cortland stuckey wants to know if we are
self-taught or if we
studied somewhere
i did not go to school for art i went to
a liberal arts college studio art was
part of my major but i did not major in
studio art i am i would say i'm
mostly self-taught
i did have in high school a mentor by
the name of ellen vartanov who is a
local legend in the washington dc area
for cartooning
and uh
she taught me
a lot of what i know and so shout outs
to ellen vartanaf who's probably not
watching but what if what if she is
what if she is i guarantee you she
should not watch it what if she's like
oh my god
kevin look at how far you've come
what about you jackie
you went to school for this i went to a
cave in the woods for four years okay
and
uh that was the name of the cave this
the cave was called
cart
cave art
uh and then wolves came and raised me
and they taught me how to draw
and it was pretty neat i like that they
taught me how to draw they didn't have
to do that they're wolves
um yeah
thanks
for the question
pretty neat question huh
i can't tell what color eye she has i
think
they're brown i'm gonna say they're kind
of a brown green
oh that's spooky i'm going to just move
that
for later huh one side is blue
one side is pink really honestly of her
hair
see
wow
that cool that's cool
very neat outfit as well it matches
their hair
i keep thinking this scratch on this
desk is a piece of my hair it's like
bothering me
that's what's up with me what's up with
you kevin oh you know all right
i know where all my hair is
okay receding ah this guy is also owned
we did it we did it turn off the stream
all right
uh do you have a question here
i have no idea how to pronounce the name
of this
okay
okay all right i have a lifelong dream
to become an animator how do i achieve
it
jackie someone on the stream wants to
know
how to become an animator
you
i don't know the answers to these
questions
you just gotta try your best
you gotta keep drawing and you gotta
stay realistic about your goals
and
you can do anything you put your mind to
like drawing someone's character
from the buzzfeed channel
if that is what you wish
um all right
okay very cool
this is gonna look a little scary but
that's because the character has like
what is the white part of your eyes the
scale of the law
the whites of your eyes what are they
called the whites of your eyes they're
called something right the whites of
your eyes no no there's something don't
shoot until you see the whites of their
eyes have you ever heard that jackie no
because i'm you know not 300 years old
wow yeah
and that was live wow
i'm sorry there is no need for me to get
so
so so cool
looks like sans undertale for a second
whoops
oh boy
okay
how many years have you been
how many years have you been drawing
jackie
probably a really long time how old am i
right now i don't even remember
i think i've been drawing since i was
like
five right you don't ever
you don't ever go like i'm going to
start drawing when i'm right 14. i've
been drawing as long as i can remember
yeah you don't you just the difference
is you some people stop drawing you know
yeah don't stop drawing don't stop
trying just don't do it oh god
all right
so
morgan
ray
this is your drawing
uh
yeah
is your drawing yeah here's the thing
let me know in the chat if this looks
like me
i bet i know what you're to say internet
is it going to be yes
[Music]
okay meanwhile i'm going to find another
one
see who we need see who we got
uh
oh okay is jackie almost done
yeah
i'm getting there
okay
wait i'm gonna make you happy
sorry if this is out of character oh
a question
i'm inferring a question why didn't you
color her glass
why didn't i color her glasses
um
i guess i could color her glasses real
quick while jackie's finishing up wow a
little extra detail just uh
astrid cruz wants me to color her
glasses it's pretty pretty so i will
pretty much standard requests listen
what do you what you don't want to mess
around with astrid cruz okay i've heard
things i've heard things too i've heard
around the
grape
vines is that the metaphor yeah just the
one anyway i'm done so hurry up all
right well now i'm not gonna color it oh
i mean i'm really i gotta do something
else now oh no
all right
no you know what i'm not gonna do it
what
you don't wanna mess with you're right i
don't wanna mess with astrid i'm gonna
do it real quick
real quick we just went through this
a little something to mine as well
the reason why i didn't do it originally
is because her glasses are mostly clear
they just have like a little bit of
detail in the edges they're like cat
eyes
so i didn't want to
um
felix asks what is the best part
jackie felix asks what's the best part
of being an animator
i
felix hello
the best part is that
yeah don't uh
don't overwhelm here
so i'm gonna look up and i'm just
kidding
uh is that every morning i get to wake
up and i get to be like i'm gonna go
draw something for work
and get paid money instead of being like
i gotta get up and do
something i'd rather not do i guess i
guess
above all i'd rather be doing this
that's a ringing endorsement
adult life is filled with suffering
all right yeah so let's uh let's start a
new
a new one
am i supposed to continue drawing
yeah we're going to roll up and do like
the intro and everything like that hey
guys
episode
so what you're gonna see right now
friends watching live on the internet is
uh how we record uh the regular draw off
episodes uh so you're gonna see our
producer buddy here matt come in with a
slate
jackie and i are going to do an intro
and then we're going to continue to draw
your profile pictures
this is bfv5
draw live
3a take one a slate
b slate
nc slate oh we gotta start our screen
recordings oh come on
oh it's just here
okay i'm rolling
where's the record button
for obs
it's just the thing on the left on the
right not there
oh how silly that's weird what a random
little thing that has happened okay
yeah let's do second sticks
hey slate
there we go there we go there you ready
wait wait oh we gotta do the intro hey
i'm jackie
this is live so i'm it's been recording
for like hours now
can we can we can we do it bright can we
do it hi guys i'm jackie
i'm gonna start how about that i mean
okay i can't even yell i normally yell
we can we can yell a little bit
all right
all right i gave me the permission to
yell
what's up i'm kevin hey i'm jaggi and
today we are drawing people's profile
pictures from memory not from memory not
from memory from a hashtag from a
previously recorded
live stream
do you want to redo that because i was
doing so rudely interrupted you okay
you ready
hey oh yep you go first then you go
first oh i go for it yeah hey i'm jackie
hey i'm kevin and today no you know what
i'll go first because i'm explaining it
guys this is how our show works
all right ready
hey i'm kevin
will you oh my god i'm trying to find
someone to do that afterwards i'll stop
i'll stop and you know what i'll draw
less people because of kevin wow yeah
this will literally take 30 seconds
i mean obviously not it's been like a
hot minute now okay you ready okay
hey i'm kevin hey i'm jackie and today
we are drawing people's profile pictures
tweeted to us using
draw off live from a previously recorded
live stream it's not from memory not
from memory that would be really hard
can it be called from memory if you have
never seen it if you've never seen it
yeah i mean if you see it and then you
look away
that could be memory should we try that
no okay these people want us to draw
them them good yeah okay understandable
so what happened was
so what happened was uh people tweeted
at us using the hashtag drawofflive and
we drew some of their
uh
profile pictures
what he said what he said
i'm looking up someone to draw right now
okay who we gonna choose
oh my god
so many people i'm gonna
uh yazinovsky says it's not live
so
right now
uh yazzanovsky says it's not like
he says it's not live but you know what
it's 4 41pm in california right now and
uh
what's a current event um
it's live
i keep looking at that camera now
my brain is out of whack
i think there's something wrong with my
twitter okay here's the thing julia
denny's you already had yours drawn
so you can't try to flatter me with your
garfield
you already got a brent
you're not satisfied with your brent i
guess not
brent original
all right
i think something's like weird with my
twitter right now because i'm trying to
scroll past like the same five photos
and it just keeps scrolling back
um
all right i just need to choose one oh
okay i got one you got one all right i'm
going to be i'm going to be drawing
i'm going to be drawing ward caden
because
i'm going to draw this cute little baby
because i love babies
yeah yeah this is a cute baby and their
name is
fortnite azaria
okay
thanks fortnight azaria
really keeping with the theme here ward
caden
this better be your real cousin fortnite
azaria here we go
so ward submitted a picture that is
pretty wild they have got some
crazy hair
really so i am looking forward to this
can i see it you want to see can i see
that's ward
wow that's a artistic picture cool
pretty pretty neat okay my eye is so
itchy i'm gonna die today today is the
day finally
okay i'm good stay with us jackie i'm
trying my best
for tonight is there
so jackie how do you approach drawing
people's likenesses
um you know if you
look at someone really fast you see
the most
you all right do we have to reboot you
what happened i don't remember what i
was going to say
you see distinctive qualities of a
person okay you know like oh
please wait while we talk to your
displays you may notice flickering or
mouse lag during this time period you
messed up that's pretty cool you messed
up okay i'm just going to move that to
the side and continue drawing
um like this baby
babies are really distinctive for their
chubby little cheeks oh that's so cute i
know and who is that this is fortnite
azaria's was in this area
fortnite created this baby okay um this
baby's gonna know so many fortnight
dances
nice um
this little baby has gum in their mouth
so cute
and they have a cute little outfit on
and you know gentle hair love it
i think babies have the cutest chubby
cheeks
so i am not a caricature artist
but i have a lot of respect for them
yeah because
likenesses are very tough for me
yeah
i learned in high school not to try to
draw my friends because they would
always say
they would always say the same thing
that's not what i look like oh and it
hurt your little feelings
it didn't hurt my feelings i just i
don't need that type of abuse
sounds like it hurt your feelings didn't
hurt my feelings jackie
okay
another good question for jw
oh my gosh jw cool boy
jw cool boy
um
do you reference real things when
drawing
so jw cool boy wants to know do we
reference things from life or do we do
it from
our heads
referencing things from life is very
very important if you don't know what it
looks like google it don't try to draw a
car from memory if you don't know what
cars look like it'll all make you a
better artist and in turn your visual
memory will expand
see that was a real that was a great
answer thank you
jackie i'm so proud of you
well
i just want to do it for fortnite's area
we all want to do it for fortnite zero
thank you fortnite azera you're the one
i think your little cousin has a bow in
her hair but
sorry if she doesn't you should try it
she's probably gonna look real cute
i feel like the person that i'm drawing
ward caden
jason would do an amazing job with
i feel like
award a jason drawing ward caden would
be
really dope should we bring him back
no he's already have a chance
did you say he's out of chances he's
already had his chance
and he blew it oh dear
baby
look at this cute little baby ah
big fat cheeks so how do you make a baby
drawing cute
uh i go for the big big big cheeks big
fluffy cheeks i go for big round eyes
uh
babies like they look kind of thick they
look silly you know
they're just like uh
they're like little people i don't know
how to say it but yeah i think they're
kind of like young small humans
who knew something about them you know
all right
all right
looking good
i'm really hungry can i leave
no jackie you have to stay here and draw
with me okay
forever oh
no
no don't go away jackie
jackie
come back
come back jackie
okay
are we just are we just not drawing i'm
drawing i'm okay it's just i'm having a
little fun
oh you hear that that was my stomach
going
i just thought i'd let you know
all right so
i don't know the name of this baby
okay i'm gonna call i'm gonna call her
gummy because she has gum in her mouth
a little gummy has brown hair
little gummy
oh
sorry i'm not coloring any line arts
because it just takes too long and i
know a billion people want drawings so
i'm just going to try my best to do that
well luckily
ward cayden
submitted theirs in black and white wow
what a genius
well i am gonna
hit them with a little bit of color just
so it's a thing well it's not just so
it's a thing it's more of a duo tone
jackie just a bit of a duo time a little
bit of a do a bit of a duo tone
all right
jessica tran says caricature here
looking good
jessica tran thank you
for
paying me a compliment
because jackie never does i compliment
you
yeah you just nev you're just never
satisfied
that's not my fault it's true
it's not
jackie how you doing doing pretty good
i'm really proud of this baby oh
look at this baby oh baby
i think that's uh as much as i can go
with the with this baby i'm gonna maybe
fill it wow what's happening right now
okay let's merge these layers
we'll never need those ever again
as far as i'm concerned
i'll do a little color i'm going to make
the gum a little
wet
a little color a little light blue
to get that kind of duo tone feel
[Music]
not there friend
down here all right i think i'm good
with mr
good old fortnite as area
uh thank you for tonight azaria for your
cute little photo of little baby
all right let's see who's next huh who's
next jackie who's next
a lot of animals in here
i love all of your
anime
original characters thank you for
showing them to me i can't draw them all
but
they're all really good
all right
all right lord cayden
ward cayden that is yours i'm gonna move
on to one more
last one jackie last one yeah really
yeah that's quite fast no we got a
switch
oh
okay so is this last one we're going to
look at each other's or sure or should
we do six
and switch
should we just stay here until it's done
stay here until the internet gets sick
of us
yeah
i'm not gonna draw bob ross teletubby
son come on
all right
let's see what we got oh my god i just
want to draw another baby but here we go
not do it
oh my god
okay i think i might
what have i drawn i've drawn
this i've drawn a person i've drawn
character
drawn baby
i think i might draw someone's pet next
oh
because it seems there's a lot of i've
drawn someone's like
characters who want their pets drawn
i've drawn people's babies and people
themselves and i drew i think my
favorite drawing is still vegetable crew
um so i think i'm going to draw
someone's pet people love drawings of
their pets
oh and you know what i just found the
best one
okay
i found this cat that they you know
poor cat they put it in a hat ah cutting
the hat you all know that book um
there you go
all right okay i got my next one
all right i am going to be drawing
suha rahan
well you know what suha
has
put up an
excellent expression
so i'm going to tackle that
i'm drawing didn't please
little good old dimples i said what i
said i'm not repeating myself
what were you muttering what i'm sorry
you want to share with the rest no i
didn't i didn't say anything all right
i'm going to draw this cat it's going to
be mad
oh my gosh i'm really hungry
ah
sorry
almost yellow
so the username somebody says don't draw
human feet on the cat
why would you say that
that just makes me want to draw feet on
the cat
should i do it
you should draw human feet on the cat
matt over there is saying yes and i
really respect matt's opinion
but i also don't want to destroy dana's
poor cat
dana didn't do anything to me you know
what i'll do two versions i'll do a
version where it's normal and fine and
inversion with feet human feet
okay
so and then you'll see and then you'll
feel and then you'll feel sorry
so i chose
suha's
photo because they
are making a great expression
that i really want to draw i like weird
expressions
cool
i don't know i didn't know what to say i
know i just thought there was nothing
else to do you don't have to react to
everything yeah i did but it was quiet
yeah pretty neat words kevin say them
again the internet does not like silence
yeah they want us to keep talking they
do want us to keep talking let's say
jokes
jokes oh let's do a shout out to jalen
nothing but nice
oh i love miss jalen simmer
jalen simmer
thank you for watching we love you this
heart i'm going to draw right now is for
you
oh
that's for you nobody else this is i
don't know how to spell it
but part of it is on the heart and
that's your heart oh that's very sweet
no one else can have that heart
um all right
this is a weird so this is a cat wearing
like a reindeer
hat okay it's kind of odd shaped little
antlers okay but i think that's what
makes them fun
so my goal
with this one is to capture this
expression with as few lines as possible
all right because i feel like maybe
that's where i screw up likenesses as i
try to use too many lines
and i feel like maybe the more abstract
you are
the more
people will
think it looks like them okay this is my
working theory all right we'll see if it
works
are you patronizing me i'm just drawing
just relax bro
i don't know where this cat is going the
picture crops quite strangely
it's just gonna have a very stumpy body
you can make it up yeah i'm doing that
kevin
i'm gonna make the drawing a little
smaller
also i'm gonna redraw the antlers i know
it has chunky antlers
but i'm going to make it look
a little cuter i feel like i messed up
trying to make it too much like it i
mean i'm already not really giving it a
real face so
there we go see i like that
oh
you
jackie have you ever been asked to draw
artwork for tattoos um
no
but i have had someone
just get my art as a tattoo really
without like
i mean i think they saw so
i'm so jealous i think they saw the
artwork somewhere like online maybe and
then they were just like that looks cool
what was it um it was a while ago i
don't even remember i just remember
being in high school being like you
could have it was in high school yeah
your high school art is permanently on
somebody's body that's quite disturbing
isn't it no it's quite cool uh i don't
know shout out to that person who did
that you don't even know who it is no i
never messaged them
someone sent it to me on
text message that's too cool jackie
whatever
i have never been asked to
draw artwork for a tattoo kevin
it's true will you
stop
don't patronize me
will you draw my next tattoo
jackie oh kevin i hope someone gets one
of these drawings you've done tattooed
yeah yeah
the thing is
if somebody wants
their face
but my face yep on their body as a
tattoo
hit me up
that's kevin can do that i can do that
i can make that happen for you kevin is
a people pleaser
okay
i mean we don't technically have to end
at five
i don't remember what tabby cats look
like but i'm trying all right
here we go wrong layer
drawing on the wrong layer how many
times have you done that jackie quite a
lot
probably more times than i've gone to
the
bathroom was a weird comparison i'm
sorry in comparison
take it back
all right who else are we shouting out
here
this cat's got green eyes
kim stewart says
human feet human feet people human feet
human feet human feet human feet human
feet human feet human feet
the internet wants you
to draw human feet okay okay i've done
the actual cat dana i'm sorry i'm about
to do this
i'm going to draw human feet on this cat
so here what i'll do is
let's
combine this
so that you have this you have this okay
i promise you know i'm i won't delete
the regular drawing but i'm about to
make this into a monstrosity
um
so i'll make a layer on top i'll lower
this opacity huh why don't we do that
let's just draw some human feet human
feet human feet human feet human feet
human feet
gotta get the accurate amount of toes
i don't know if anyone will answer
should
this cat have
four human feet or that one
okay all four of the feet are going to
be human feet i guess that's matt wants
that way
and mets i can't wait
i trust matt's that taste
i probably shouldn't but
i'm already here you know the chat
agrees
thank you chat you're such a lovely
little
insane group of people
can i get some human feet chats
chances yeah let's get some human feet
chants in the in the chat in the chat
please human feet human feet human feet
i don't even know what this is going to
look like
this
i see the outline of what's happening
and i'm quite i'm afraid you're afraid
i'm afraid of the results
okay let's i believe in you thank you
you shouldn't
but i'll take it
all right
oh it's the wrong um
here i want it to be a surprise i want
us all to react to it
together
so let's do that i'm going to do it all
in low opacity so
it just be slowly becomes
something we all should i paint the
toenails oh absolutely okay matt pick a
color
all right oh to match the obviously to
match the head
okay and i don't want to mess with
astrid listen if there's one thing we've
learned today you don't mess with astrid
no no no astro crews
look at what you've done
look at this this cat doesn't deserve to
be here
have you created a monstrosity i've
created something awful just awful wow
but i'm going to continue
that's losing it
my favorite thing
all right uh i'm going to give it it has
human feet so it can't be covered human
do we do it should i draw a tail foot
the internet wants you to draw a tail
foot if you guys really want me to draw
a tail foot i'll draw you a tail foot
foot tail foot let me finish the the
foot foot first
okay i can only do one thing at a time
oh i'd mess that up
they all they've also requested antler
foot all right
i you know what this is going off the
rails jackie no i'm gonna do it
it'll be worth it in the end right
oh gosh um you
you
all right um
i'm painting the nails astrid please
don't please don't find me
i'm painting the nails oh you look
beautiful i'm so sorry to this cat like
it's really the victim is this cat
meanwhile i'm drawing a normal person
uh i mean see where that takes you
because i'm having the time of my life
can't use that can we not nope i sang it
in a completely wrong tone
so it's fine
all right so we got we got foot foot you
want you guys want a tail foot tail tail
foot next tail foot tail how about if
it's a hand let's get some other other
body parts in there right
no
[Music]
all right chat hand tail tail hand or
tail foot
i'm gonna start on the foot antlers
first so you guys can you know
have a chance at it
ah
oh boy what have i done delightfully
chaotic said hand foot and i don't
really know what to do with that
uh
hand foot
what is the tail hand is the winner tail
hand is the winner all right
how about i give this cat human ears
should we do that or should we go with
foot antlers
i don't know matt's giving me a face
matt really wants foot antlers to happen
all right all right matt don't worry
about it
how close are you to finishing i've been
done i'm just drawing this
i'm
mutating this cat against its will okay
i'm almost done so we can switch in a
minute okay do you want to see the real
cat or do you want to see the office i
want to see the awful monstrosity that
you've unleashed upon the world okay
and this cat is 300 feet tall so what
that's my head cannon
these feeders
okay
um this feat is quite chunky i don't
know what happened but
it's there what color should the should
the toenails of the
of the antler feet be different
than uh the the
the paw
foot the foot what i have no idea what
you're saying right now uh listen
there's a lot going on in my life there
is a lot going on there's go there's a
lot going on right now i don't really
know how to deal with it really
all right um
this looks great
right a lot of
votes green all right it's getting
christmas up in here
um
is
why why do you guys want this
the internet just wants to control you
jackie i mean it's working they don't
really care about what you draw they
just want they just want it to happen
who
make it happen i feel it i mean
you guys are power hungry
should i make the should i make the
toenails shiny
like
this cat got some gel nails i'm already
doing it i don't want you guys to answer
don't talk to me anymore i am i am
finished i'm i got to draw the tail hand
add some details add some details okay
add some details
okay well that's awful um hand time
i have an image in my head of what this
is it's not good and yeah
it don't whatever you're imagining
get rid of it because it's worse than
that
yeah
don't do this but shout out to rachel g
who said french tips
i got my nails done recently guys are
they pretty do you like them this one's
broken ah
anyway yeah more drawing oh yeah more
drawing i gotta finish this you gotta
finish this what should i do to the face
please don't worry i've already there's
been plenty of suggestions
no more
matt says it's done matt feels matt's
starting to feel bad for the cat
unless you want to give it a toe nose
all right that's that's easy that's easy
what are you going to do toenos a
toenails to nose
what do you knows okay
got him
how did you get me with that i just got
you don't worry about it
i'm gonna make this hand my hand
because i got nice nails
and i just feel like i deserve this
i don't like it
no
it's scary
this is like a silent hill monster
all right
great
looking good
i guess
oh
are you done yet i'm
drawing you know how hard it is to draw
uh
five feet and one hand and one toe
quite hard
turns out this poor cat
this poor poor cat merge these layers
again i'm just i'm lazy coloring now i
mean i've been lazy coloring but even
more so i guess
these are pink because my nose are pink
i like pastel but whatever i want you
guys to be able to ah be able to see it
sorry i made a mistake so i screamed
obviously
all right i'm almost done kevin can you
relax a little bit i'm totally relaxed
well whatever it doesn't seem like okay
tonos
um i don't know even how to do that
okay
um
i guess
what is the chat saying i guess
various reactions maybe mist says can i
adopt this cat oh of course you can
and i'm going to color this one
color this is
now let's do green let's degree
make it metallic
thanks i hate it
i can't wait to see it oh my god
ew
okay let's let's look at the original
cute
horrible
cute
monstrous monstrous mascara let me see
let me see all right are you ready are
we doing a switch yeah we're going to do
a switch we're going to switch i'm
leaving up
zuha here so you can see yeah oh can i
show you the wait can i show you the cat
it's just a cat yeah show me the german
you leave the leave the actual cat up oh
yeah okay here's some cats
all right
can we shake hands on the way
sorry it was a little late i almost
tripped on some wires good work
what the hell is this
oh my god sorry
i mean it's not my fault really it's
just the fault of the viewers
this is frightening
yeah
wow okay so it's got
it's got
feet for ears
it's got
people feet for feet it's got a hand for
tail
and it's got a toe for a nose yeah
this should not exist you should not
exist just stop it
this cat's that's just what the cat
looks like
this is frightening this is what happens
when you let the internet dictate what
you draw yeah so this is why we don't
let the internet just make world
decisions because you get
you get
five toe yeah you get five feet you get
this poor poor cat this cat wants who
can't hear
but can run anywhere just any in any
direction really
um i love this
i think you got the expression does it
look like me
no it doesn't okay i think it's
impossible for this drawing i don't
think i've ever seen you make this face
please don't do that i don't like
looking at that
anyway i don't think it looks like you i
think it looks just like suha
rihan thank you
it's good it's got
the energy
it's got
i don't know what else to say expression
okay that's what they are called when
your face makes different movements
based on your moods they're called
expressions
so what do you so what do you think
about uh drawing
so what do you think about
drawing likenesses based off of
pictures that people send us it's pretty
fun i like it you like this yeah would
you do it again sure sure can i get paid
no
okay then i don't want to do it again
we're doing this for free
people don't know this but we don't get
paid to do this we are trapped
trapped in this room they just let us
out until we draw yeah the right thing
we will never leave here yeah so please
don't be too harsh on us we haven't
we haven't seen light we've tried i was
really hoping that this horrible
horrible cat would be the drawing that
would unlock us from this place yeah and
you know what it's not even enough i
should have gone with a even more
horrible
suggestions maybe next time next time
when we are let out of our drawing cages
again
that's a wrap let's get the the clicky
thing
you do that at the beginning not at the
end you don't do it at the end no why
parker we're gonna keep talking until
literally everyone stops watching marker
how many viewers are we at right now
whoa you got a gaming setup is it
dropping okay look at the gaming setup
all right look at it it's nice it's nice
uh let's go ahead and cut the cameras
and then
we will say goodbye to the internet
bye
is there anything else that you want to
say
no don't mess with astrid don't mess
with astrid jw cool boy but jw cool boy
we f with you
we can't curse on the stream yeah
but
if we could all right thank you for
watching the first draw off live who
knows if we do this again let's just
never do it again well let's be a little
nicer about it i don't think we're ever
doing this ever again it was an awful
and
just traumatizing experience
i think i'll never recover thank you so
much for nothing
i hope you guys all cry today okay
to see this is why we don't let jackie
live on the internet and i hope you guys
stub your toes and
i hope you break your nails all right
all right let's end the stream just
click stop goodbye internet we love you
you lose your hat okay that's cool
that's waving